united nations investigators are
returning to syria they're resuming
inspections of alleged chemical weapons
attacks that were halted amid fears of a
possible military strike on damascus
earlier this month
the investigators confirmed last week
that the nerve gas sarin was used in the
august massacre so the u.n is
negotiating a response
un secretary general ban ki-moon has met
with foreign ministers from members of
the u.n security council
and they appear to be making some
progress behind closed doors
we have a few details
to
solve but uh i think
that
we shall
reach
a common resolution
maybe today or tomorrow it doesn't solve
the problem of syria but it's a step
moscow has offered to send officials to
syria to confirm the destruction of the
country's chemical weapons arsenal
but syria still refuses to accept any
blame
in an interview with venezuelan
television syrian president assad
repeated his claim that rebels were
responsible for the chemical attacks in
damascus and said he has provided proof
to the russians
but agreeing to a peaceful solution
could become more complicated a number
of islamist rebel brigades have
withdrawn their support of the syrian
national council which so far has been
the west's main negotiating partner from
the opposition
you